everybody is playing their 20s backwards
if you guys understood that you could
accomplish nothing for the next eight
years and I mean zero and still be young
as [__] and like dominate life you would
get on a plane and spend the next two
years going everywhere because there's
no downside and there's nothing but
upside everybody's got such a chip on
her shoulder between debt or to prove to
somebody that they've got something that
they go right into dumb [__] to start
getting short money and like do the
right thing or prove something the 22 to
30 year old play should be even more
ridiculous than 18 to 22. I think you
guys should [__] go around the world
as a horde living shitty places like
learn taste play